my granddad taught me how to fish it was
like part of like you know going to the
cottage jade i know that you are a dad
you have the son what are some of the
traditions you want to pass along to him
there's a ton of things that you get to
enjoy when you grow up in the country
that you know
you take for granted sometimes like you
can't really walk out naked on your
porch anywhere but i used to do like i
just used to live freely like that i
didn't know you're a nudist at heart
there jader
it's amazing i've never tried it i think
i'd get a call
might get in trouble
yeah yeah you can get away with a lot in
the country
this song is so much fun more drinking
than fishing so i have to ask who's
better at drinking i actually probably
drank more beer than jade this past year
i drank a lot of beer
i put my kogit 19 on right here
he's saying that before the video he's
like oh you're looking great like i'm
you know i'm i'm not feeling confident
but they showed up and he's like just
got it's almost like his arms are
photoshopped i've had a couple people
actually asking the pictures like dean
photoshopped his arms and like what no i
just i was i swear to god man i'm just
kind of like yeah he did yeah give us a
demo dean let get you know
he's like nah i got my honey on
[Music]
so aside from learning that jade is a
nudist uh dean what did you learn about
jay while working with him he actually
was pretty good at
navigating a boat the way you handled
that thing my first time honestly i'm
not a water person i can't swim very
well so i i just stay clear i've seen
you swim buddy it's it's uh it's
something
[Music]